MUSK TO Y
PLATISW LLL WHEN
THE BILLO FIRS BECOME S RGR, SE
TA TRIED T
FIGHBLST MUSANNOUNCED THAT
HE WAS PULLING OTHDEH THATWINTR
FRIDAY MUS G HIOU
FUSCATING FANDH
STOC MUSK MADE HIS
BEST AND FINAL0 A
SHARE.
IT CLOSED FRIDAY AT 4,
.
TWITTER'S LEGAL  FTHAT MUSHAHE
DI THANSUMMATED.
TWITR  ILAINT
E O CHANGE HISH THIS ORA DED WA
SCOTT OW PROFESSOR FOUNDED
NINE COMPANIES, AND THAUE BOOKS
RENT
CR TO OPRT, AND HIS LOG AT N ITR
THE Y, RIGHTITSUFFERABLE, WELCO
BACK, I ENJOYED YOUR O
ND THI  THINK I HAVE
THE MOST
THE BESOU HAVE SOMEONE
TERED INTO A CONTRACTUAL
DED  OUT OE AL'S NOWA
RIDICULOUS P BLE
SO THIS IS INK HE WANTS OUT.
HE'S NOT JUS
PRICE NO,ICELN TH
E RUTOAN F MONED IR SELA
SUBSTANTIAL
SHARES WHICH HAVCLLU WN
DAYS, HE RRSAL, SOABSOLUTE OPOI
A 20% PREMIBU AM TO WHERE THE .
NEGOTIATE, REDUCE PRE HERE.
SORT OF ANRRO ANSANE DEAL, AT TH
>> I AG
Y, INCLUDING THE TESLA ANTH
FROAGANL WHOSE CS
UNLLY DAMAGED THANY'S RETAA
CHILL ON ADVERTISING, BAPL MHAGD
LEGAVIEW OLE
SAY IF THE ATH
STHASE AGREEMENTS
FOR MP
3% OF GH, A RIVER WITHOUT A  HE
DEY T DATE BECAUSE HE
S  MOVE IT TSITUATION WH THE
ANBO
HOPING THEY WILL ACQUIESCE AND
SAY WEP    P AND LET HIM OUT MIE
E MARKAREHOLDER NOT ONLY REPRES
THATS  AP INTTER, IT  OWNER
THE WEALTHIEST MAN IN THE WORLD
WH IS GOING TO B54A SHARE
ISFAOOT FOR BILLION HERET
LL>> WOW, ,
SC OFF TO DELAWARELLORY  BUILTFP
THEY DON'T HAVE OPENING
NTS.
THE A JURY.
I THINK THEY TO
I THEN THI IT DEPOSETO CLOSE.
IT THEN GOES TO LEMENT.
WE DON'TU TO AND MUSK WILL SAY
THE TO
I THINK THE TTLENT
CHARACTERS HERE AND THZES L BUT
GRMERETTY AIA, AND THERE'SNT FOT